we played plus 40 minutes last couple  nights and played a lot of minutes so  far this year  steve said he's going to look for a  night somewhere to get you a night off  are you concerned at all about the  workload that you put in so far today  no let me die out there  no i'm just playing  i know i'm not concerned but whenever  coach um  want to give me a date and you know i'll  support it but i'm not looking for one  you get what i'm saying so i'm gonna  just play until they  tell me that  i'm sitting up you know but that's not  on my mind while i'm playing that's not  on my mind when i'm going into a game  preparing for a game  it is what it is i gotta play 40. i  gotta play  so what you know what i'm saying i'm  gonna play but if they tell me to sit  out i'm gonna do the same thing